all right everybody the holidays are
almost here and even though we might be
celebrating
through facetime or zoom this year sucks
um i promise you there will be no
shortage though of awkward moments with
your family
that's right it always happens someone's
probably gonna fight too it's mine
[Music]
to ease your struggles this season
though we ask y'all to send in your
biggest dilemmas
so i can help solve them for you i'm so
helpful so here goes nothing
[Music]
i do christmas with my dad's not so fun
side of the family
this year i used quarantine as an excuse
to go with my mom's side instead by
telling my aunt
we were staying home then accidentally
put her in a group chat
about going with the fun ones am i going
to hell
no but you are in so much trouble
here's the thing don't lie just own it
and then be like look
why don't you become maybe this is your
opportunity to become the fun ones
you know like just own it you can't lie
in that situation you just gotta be like
i
sorry it was a turd statement i do stand
by it
but but yeah maybe let's do something to
turn it around
a little fun little family game maybe
come up with i don't know
but basically you just yeah you dug that
hole and you're just sitting in it yep
it happens to the best of us
when the discussion turns to politics
oh you should yeah here's the thing
i'm the i'm not a good person to ask
about this because i don't think most
people like my answer
i don't like when people say don't talk
about faith
or politics or all the big issues
because i'm like that's how we get here
that's how we get to 2020.
no one talks about stuff like this is a
that doesn't
fix the problem like and and it doesn't
help
um in any way shape or form on either
side you know what i'm saying
and why would you not want to have
conversations about stuff like that
because maybe
just maybe what i think about something
isn't really right not and i didn't
really think about it in that way or
that vantage point or perspective and
like i don't i don't know
my mom and i are my mother and i are
very different on on
some things but you know wanting to be
loved and respected and helpful and
a servant's heart like there are a lot
of core things there like
granted we are different and in some
other ways but i think that that that's
not
that's not a problem i mean that's one
reason why i love that i was born in
america reading all that stuff in
history while we were just reading it
for fun that was the whole point people
got to come here and you got to believe
what you wanted to believe and you got
to be
who you want to be and and that should
be celebrated um
but i do think that you know no progress
will happen no change will happen unless
we
talk about it
do you think people would rather like
homemade gifts or bought gifts i think
homemade
i'm worried that no one wants to be
creative and makes fun stuff anymore
well then don't be friends with him
that's my thing
like i mean whatever you're into like
hang out with people who like that too
i love making stuff not only just
because it's fun to create something but
also it's like therapeutic you're just
sitting there like when i color with my
kids
yeah i'm doing it because it's fun with
them and they love it and they ask me to
do it but also it's like
really soothing oddly i used to i'm
gonna be real
laugh at people when i saw adults with
coloring books i'd be like what
and i didn't get it and now i am one of
them
i you know it's really therapeutic and
and and this has been a hard year
what should be on my virtual christmas
party playlist
um underneath the tree
under the mistletoe by kelly clarkson
brad eldridge apparently i've discovered
i like that's not going to sound good um
[Laughter]
never mind i just use the word under a
lot and i didn't realize that well just
i used it twice
but it was funny i was like oh i didn't
realize i did that
no in all seriousness that was a joke um
but
i love it depends on what vibe you're
going for
you know are you looking for like wham
last christmas like mariah carey
christmas album like that kind of like
up tempo dino ross kind of vibe like
or are you looking for like that john
legend being crosby
like throwback kind of vibe i don't know
what is your part is there a theme
like you can have a theme zoom
christmas party that sounds sad even as
i said it
yeah and with that happy holidays